they build these nests of leaves that
are pulled together and woven by their
larvae yes they use child labor they
roam around and leap on you Oh what they
do is they bite into your skin and then
they spray formic acid on the wound
really wakes you up good way to start
today
here we are preparing for Nancy's just
outside they're hanging for one in the
small village where they all it for all
the kids let's see how they like it
Carrot Top Ramen temple we're gonna see
of these tourism like these yummy ants
as much as we all did yesterday vomit
with a special local ingredients very
fresh which which is what are they again
they are lies they are these holes a
little cardamon a little soul some ant
larvae and ant love it wait did I say
hmm you put the ones without the ant
larvae on this sound it's actually quite
tasty we have an Australian here and you
know the only you know you get some clay
and molded into the shape of a cow and
it's gone it's just too easy with
Australia okay okay we're going for it
was it gonna Park everybody loves the
ants so I think 70 nationalities here
but the French of refuse us every time